اعلنت ايون ان الولايات المتحده وافقت على
صفقه اسلحه معها بقيمه تزيد على 600 مليون
دولار بهدف تعزيز قدراتها الدفاعيه واوضحت
وكاله التعاون الامني الدفاعي الامريكيه
ان صفقه تتضمن صواريخ ومعدات تستخدمها
مقاتلات اف 16 وصواريخ مضاده للاشعاع
واخرى من نوع جو جو وراجمات صواريخ وقد
اعربته وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه عن
امتنانها للموافقه الامريكيه على هذه
الصفقه التي يتوقع ان تدخل حيز التنفيذ
بعد يوم واحد من اخطار الكونجر الامريكي
بها
وفي بيجين انتقدت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
موافقه واشنطن على صفقه الاسلحه لتايوان
وقالت المتحدثه باسم الوزاره ان الولايات
المتحده انتهكت التزامها السياسي بشان
قضيه تايوان من خلال بيعها اسلحه متطوره
وحثت واشنطن على وقف بيع الاسلحه للجزيره